And now it's the old scout master.
We're looking out over camp and in our part of the world recently the American Bald Eagle has returned
and now has a nesting site actually on the property of our camp.
We feel very privileged and we were looking out and we saw an eagle soaring way up in the sky there-
Just the most beautiful, majestic sight, as you would expect.
And also off we saw a few hawks flying by
And I asked one of the fellows with me if he knew an easy way to tell the difference between hawks and eagles
And he said no, I really don't.
I said: well, it's the wingtip feathers which are called pinions.
They're a good indicator.
Eagles have five and hawks have four.
And some people say it's just a matter of opinion.
Yeah, a matter of opinion.
Oh my,
Don't blame me for that one folks.
That's Tony Rotswell.
Thank you, Tony.
He sent the story in.
Hey, this is podcast number 73..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Greene. heard from Larry this week who said:
I just wanted to say that the podcast and the interview was great.
That was last podcast. we interviewed the author of the Scoutmaster's Other Handbook
and the Eagle Court of Honor Handbook, Mark Ray,
who was generous enough to sit and talk with us for a bit.
I've listened to you interview several people and I have to compliment you on your interview style.
You've got a great delivery and a great program.
Well, thanks, Larry.
I sure appreciate that.
Other news this week: let's see. looking around,
It's June and so people are out doing what they should be doing.
They're outside,
They're camping,
They're off with their troops.
Summer camp is right around the corner.
It's an exciting part of the year.
We've got big plans for our troop this year.
We're off for a week of summer camp here at the end of July and then we're off to Switzerland
to visit Kondersteg International Scout Center in Switzerland for a week.
So it's going to be a very exciting and very busy summer.
Over on Facebook this week, well, we hit a nice big milestone
because we got 1,000 fans on Facebook now.
So thanks very much, folks.
This time around on the Scoutmaster podcast, we're going to listen to a story.
This is a story of a scouting hero of mine, and I'm sure that most of you will share the same opinion-
and we have to tell these stories.
We have to keep this stuff in front of us.
It's part of our history as a movement, and I think it's inspiring to be able to go back
and to look at how things happened and what got us and who got us to where we are today.
So all the way, let's get started, shall we?
This has to be the truth, folks, because there is no way anyone could make this up.
The year is 1926, we're in New Jersey-
Yeah, New Jersey- and we're in a warehouse
and a crate, a big heavy crate of World War I surplus semaphore flagpoles.
It sounds like a bad joke, I know, but this actually happened.
This big heavy crate shifted and fell
and because of that the whole face of worldwide scouting changed.
Now I'm a little ahead of the story, obviously
Now understand why that crate is so important.
We've got to go back about 26 years and then we have to go a considerable distance
from that warehouse in New Jersey.
We've got to go all the way over the Atlantic to Ahu's, Denmark.
In August of 1900, a boy was born in the city of Ahu's,
named Wilhelm Biharagard Jensen.
Wilhelm grew up and became a boy who liked to go roaming through the woods outside Ahu's.
His older brother, Harold, sent him a Christmas present one year,
and that Christmas present was the book Baden Powell's Scouting for Boys.
The book had been a big smash success all over Europe
and had been translated into Danish.
Well, Wil read the book and discovered that Scouts did the kind of things that he wanted to do
when he was out there in the woods: hiking and tracking and camping
and cooking over fires and all this great stuff.
And he also discovered that to become a Boy Scout you had to join a patrol.
Well, there was no patrol around, not that Wil knew about.
So he got his buddies together and he made up a patrol.
That patrol did the sort of adventurous stuff that he had hoped they would do.
They got out in the woods outside of Ahu's and went camping and hiking.
But they had meetings that kind of devolved into some kind of rough tumble games
that Wil didn't particularly care for.
And besides that, about 1912 there was a big downturn in the Danish economy
and Wil's family needed to move and follow his father's work from place to place for several years.
Four years later Wil and his family were back in Ahu's.
Wil was a bit older and he formed his patrol. he was their patrol leader
and they just went scouting all the time.
They camped on an island on a nearby lake and they put together theatrical presentations
with other patrols to raise some money.
They tramped around the countryside, they hiked and camped one summer
all along the west coast of Denmark and Wil just flourished.
He attained the rank of night scout, which was the highest in Danish scouting in 1917.
His circle of influence grew. his patrol was now part of a real troop
and he was the most senior patrol leaders and often led the group as a whole.
He came into contact with other scout troops in the community
and began to see the wider circle of scouting as it formed in those early days.
By the time he was 20 years old, Wil was still involved with scouts who was helping lead his troop
and he was also studying to become a pharmacist.
But then he was selected to go to the First World Jamboree at Olympia in London
and that's where he first met Baden Powell.
Going to that First World Jamboree really spiked Wil's interest.
He began to get very serious about his leadership in scouting.
He became the scout master of the troupe in Ahus and a trainer in national training courses.
He began to write for the National Danish Scout Journal and then he actually became its editor.
His interest in journalism grew. he also wrote for newspapers
and he published a book when he was 23 years old.
It was a novel, it was called The Island and it was based on his experience with his patrol.
At the age of 25, Wil decided that he needed to see more of the world.
His interest was piqued by going to the World Jamboree.
He decided what he was going to do was travel around the world
and kind of investigate scouting in other countries and bring the best ideas back to Denmark.
So he started out in the United States and that year when he traveled to the United States
he got a job in a scout camp. and after the scout camp season was over
he managed to wrangle himself a job, a very menial job- in the offices of the Boy Scouts of America.
And that's where Wil came into contact with that famous crate of World War I, surplus semaphore flagpoles,
I mean, come on.
So he's moving the crate around, the crate slips and falls and it traps his leg, his right leg,
and it breaks his right leg. and so Wil is now in a foreign country somewhere,
but he's being well taken care of. he's got a busted leg. he ends up laid up for a week in the hospital
but, you know, pretty soon. he's on crutches and he's moving around.
So once Wil was out of the hospital he was back at the offices
and he had a chance encounter with the chief scout executive, James West.
Now, you know, the BSA was a relatively small operation at the time
and West knew who Wil was, at least by an accident report,
and saw him on the crutches there and he said: hey, how you doing?
Oh, I'm doing fine. What do you think of the Boy Scouts of America?
And Wil gave him a brief answer right there in person.
but he also decided that he really wanted to carefully answer West's question
because Wil was a serious man and he had made this work the aim of his life.
So he sat down and he composed an 18 page single spaced memo
and kind of dissected the BSA's strengths and weaknesses.
He had a lot of good things to say about American scouting,
but he wasn't too sure that there wasn't this kind of mania for collecting merit badges.
He thought the camps were a little soft, They were a little luxurious.
Most important, Wil said troops weren't really using the patrol method that Baden Powell had set up.
Well, West read the memo and discovered that he had a very articulate, well studied young man
working for him in a warehouse who really had a handle on some things about scouting.
So West persuaded him to become part of the BSA's editorial service.
One thing led to another. One of Wil's suggestions had been
that there really needed to be some kind of a guide for patrol leaders
if the patrol method was really to be applied.
and he was pretty insistent that it should be written by somebody
who had been a patrol leader or been a scout master.
and so West kind of called his bluff on that and said:
well, why don't you write it?
Well, that was all that Wil needed to hear,
and he started working hard putting things together.
Now I'm still calling him Wil, but by that time he was calling himself Bill,
and the reason that he did that he kind of Americanized his name.
He had Americanized his name and he changed from Wilhelm Beherrgaard Jensen
to Wilhelm Beherrgaard.
But he noticed that people at the BSA office had a little trouble with Beherrgaard
and it was coming a little bit out like Beergarden
and he didn't like the association.
So he freely translated his Danish name, Beherr, which means hill,
and Gard, which means court, to Hillcourt
and Wilhelm and William. that worked,
so he became known as William Hillcourt
and to his friends, Bill.
So now you know who Wil is right,
William Greenbar. Bill Hillcourt
the author of the first handbook for patrol leaders,
and it was published in 1929
and translated into five other languages
for use around the world.
While he was working at the BSA offices,
Bill met his wife, Grace Brown,
who worked on the chief executive staff,
and Grace was from Yonkers,
and by June of 1933
Grace Brown became Grace Hillcourt.
After a long honeymoon to Europe
and trekking around and cycling through Europe,
they returned back home
and Bill began writing and editing Scouting Magazine.
Once the handbook for patrol leaders was published,
Bill was pulled in on another job
and that was aimed at saving Boys Life Magazine.
It was the midst of the depression.
Boys Life was not doing well
and the Rockefeller Foundation made a small loan
to help keep Boys Life afloat,
and Bill's contribution was a single page
in each month's magazine
aimed at patrol leaders
and the members of their patrol
and all the great stuff patrols could do
and how they could advance together through Scouting,
all the great activities they could do.
and so the boy who had been a patrol leader in Ahus
now became America's patrol leader,
and Greenbar Bill was born
In the years that followed,
Bill's role expanded from being the BSA's chief journalist
on Scoutcraft and troop leadership
to becoming one of the primary program researchers
and developers,
and he did this in a really interesting way,
a very hands-on kind of guy.
He found a perfect location,
the village of Mendham, New Jersey,
just outside of the newly donated Shift Scout Reservation.
Bill and Grace talked Dr West
into allowing them to convert an old stone sheep barn
into a house for the two of them
where they could be close to the troop
that he was the scoutmaster for
Mendham New Jersey's troop. one
was the experimental troop of the BSA
In 1935, while they were there at Shift Scout Reservation,
Bill and Grace met Olive and Robert.
You know who Olive and Robert are- right,
Baden Powell.
That's a familiar name in Scouting,
the founder of Scouting.
Lord and Lady Baden Powell
were on a visit to the United States
and they were happy to meet
with people at Shift Scout Reservation
and the training center there
and they became a particularly fond of Bill and Grace
and it started a lifelong friendship
with Lord and Lady Baden Powell
and continued with their children and grandchildren.
Bill became one of the most familiar faces
and names in Scouting in the United States.
He wrote articles for Scouting magazine.
He wrote articles for Boys Life.
He wrote two editions of the Handbook for Scoutmasters,
two editions of the Boy Scout Handbook.
He wrote the first Scout Field Book,
which just became a classic text
on basic campcraft and nature lore.
He took wood badge training under John Skinner Wilson.
He was the camp chief of Gilwell Park in 1936.
And after World War II
Bill was instrumental in bringing
wood badge courses to the United States
and he became the first Gilwell Deputy Camp Chief
in the United States in 1948
and the first BSA Wood Badge Scoutmaster.
He edited Baden Powell's Scouting for Boys
and aided it to Scoutmastership
to be used to help revitalize Scouting
in war-torn countries,
and the books have been translated
into more than 20 languages.
He helped develop junior leader training courses
and new requirements for Boy Scout advancement.
He corresponded with Scouters in other countries,
devising them on training.
He met Scouters from around the nation
and the world at national and world jamborees
in which he was always in attendance.
Bill retired from professional service
with the BSA in 1965
and he was able to put into print
something that he had been working on
for a long time
with Grace and Lady: Baden Powell.
that was the first authoritative biography of Baden Powell,
published under the title Baden Powell:
Two Lives of a Hero.
It was translated into seven foreign languages
and became the standard reference work
on Baden Powell for many, many years.
Bill and Grace traveled widely.
They visited Scout friends
and helped to implement training programs
for Scout associations all over the world.
and Grace died in 1973,
leaving Bill bereft of his great friend
and companion.
but he pressed on with his volunteer work
in scouting.
In the 1970s the BSA made some changes.
Bill didn't like those changes at all.
He watched the BSA de-emphasize
the outdoor aspects of scouting
and try and make some pretty desperate moves
to remain relevant.
but in 1978
Bill convinced chief scout executive
Harvey Price
to allow him to write
a new Boy Scout Handbook
and bring back the outdoor orientation
to the Boy Scouts of America.
and Bill did this for free
and he spent a year
and brought out the ninth edition
entitled the official Boy Scouts Handbook,
and it was an immediate success
and it really did serve to revitalize scouting
again again.
This was his second go-around
at the age of 78
and his efforts were recognized
by the National Court of Honor
and he was awarded the silver buffalo
for distinguished service to American youth.
Bill spent his last years
as a worldwide goodwill ambassador
for scouting
and he tried to never miss a jamboree
or big encampment.
and even though it had been
some time since he had written a column
for Boy's Life magazine,
his signature was still highly sought after.
and that signature
was kind of interesting,
This Bill signature
superimposed on two green bars.
At the 1989 National Jamboree
people lined up for hours
and Bill signed 7,423 autographs
in the middle of
a hot Virginia summer
at the age of 89..
One of those 7,423 autographs
is right here
while I'm speaking to you,
a copy of the original
fieldbook that Bill wrote.
that I happen to have
and I brought to the jamboree with me
and I stood in line
and I got to meet the man for just a moment.
He was sitting at a table there
signing books very happily,
and when he saw that original copy
of the fieldbook come across
he looked at it
and he looked up at me
and he looked at his assistant
and he turns a two-fer
And what he meant
when he said that was
that he would put both signatures.
he would put the Bill signature with the green bars
and his more formal signature in it.
and I have it and it's a treasured little artifact
that I have today
from that very brief meeting
with really one of Scouting's heroes.
It all started
with that big crate
of World War I surplus
7,4 flagpoles-
and it led to something
that changed Scouting
permanently
and to something that we've
still benefit from today:
the generous, generous heart
of a great man, William Greenbar
Bill Hillcourt.
He passed away on November 9
of 1992 while he was on a
Scouting tour. He was in Sweden.
he was very close to his home
and his boyhood home in Denmark,
but he passed away there
and was brought back
to New Jersey and has entered
next to his beloved grace there
in Cemetery in New Jersey
and somebody who's well remembered.
now, if you haven't read
the original
Patrol Eater's Handbook,
if you haven't read the old
fieldbook, the first edition of the fieldbook,
you know it's worth getting a copy,
it's worth looking at and you can
virtually shake hands
with Greenbar Bill Hillcourt
Music.
Thanks for listening. Here's how to keep in touch.
You need the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
When you get to the Scoutmaster blog
you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter
and that's a monthly digest
of the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
with some great Scouting resources
around a monthly theme.
Each newsletter also includes a giveaway
and this month
the theme is going to be the patrol method
and the giveaway is going to be
several copies of
working the patrol method,
which is just a wonderful book
and will transform the way you look at Scoutmaster
Music.
You can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes
and you do feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
You can call and leave a voicemail, comment
or question at 484-734-0002.
Follow us at Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook,
join the 1000 plus fans there
and ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter.
You can email me,
Clark Green, with your comments and questions
at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet
Music.
Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Now, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
Music.
Before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Thank you, sir.
Until next time.
Music,
Music
Music.